in this tutorial I'm going to walk you
through the API connect developer portal
now we're going to enable the developer
portal for the sandbox catalog a
developer portal is a web application
for exploring subscribing sharing and
providing feedback on the api's that you
have published for now choose the
sandbox catalog click the Settings tab
and click the portal sub tab now select
the IBM developer portal radio button
and click Save the developer portal will
take some time to become active when
it's ready
you'll receive an email with a link to
confirm your account now let's take a
look at the portal if you have enabled
your portal and confirmed your account
go to settings select the portal tab and
click the URL to navigate to your
developer portal to get started with the
developer portal click on the API
products tab it contains a collection of
products published by the organization
browse through the catalogue and find
the product that suits your purpose for
this demo we'll be working with the API
smart product click it to view the
product details and plans select the API
on the left to view its operations click
on an operation to view it's details and
you can try a sample request using any
of the display languages in order to use
this API in your own application you
will need to create an account or login
with your existing account after you've
been logged in a new tab called apps
will appear on the top nav bar you need
to register a new application in order
to use the API so that are available to
you click on apps and then click on
register new application enter the title
and description of the application and
hit submit a message will be displayed
on your screen saying application
created successfully along with the
client ID and client secret for your
application you must supply the client
ID and client secret when you call an
API that requires them make a note of
your client secret because it is only
displayed once now you're ready to
subscribe to the product of your choice
open the API products tab
click on the product and hit subscribe
on the pop-up menu select your
application to sign up for this plan and
hit subscribe the product will be
displayed in the subscriptions now go to
the product detail page and test out any
operation from the list of operations
click call operation you will get a
response as displayed and now you're
ready to use the API in your own app
thanks for watching